E
ELECTRIC VEHLES.
SOUNDS LIKE A GREAT PLAN.
JOINING US WITH REACTION'S
FORMER SENIOR COUNSELOR TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP,
KELLNNE CONWAY.
OUT KICK FOUNDER CLAY TVIS
PEER AND FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR
CHARLIE HURT.
KELLYANNE, WHERE TO STA.
THER ARE SO MANY SERIOUS
ASPECTS TO WHAT WAS REPORTED ON
WITH WHAT IS GOING ON AT OUR
BORDER AND JOE BEN IS IN
SEATTLE ON EARTH DAY TALKING
ABOUT ELECTRIC TANKS.
I DON'T KNOW HOW TO SQUARE THAT
CIRCLE.
>> NON OF THIS MAKES ANY SENSE.
GO TO SEATTLE, RGHLY 4700-MILE
ROUND-TRIP EMITTING ENOUGH
CARBON THAT REPRENTS ABOUT
EIGHT AMERICANS CARN OUTPUT
FOR THE YEAR, TOUGH
R FORCE ONE, AND THEN TO NOT
EVEN MEMORIZE AOUPLE OF GOOD
LINES, TO NOT EVEN BE ABLE TO BE
CONVERSANT OR CPELLING OR
PERSUASIVE OR MEMORABLE,
JOE DEN TALKS LIKE THAT EVERY
SINGLE DAY FOR FREE WITHOUT
GOING ANYWHERE EXCEPT WALKI
DOWN TO THE RESIDENCE IN T
WHITE HOUSE.
WE DIDT NEED HIM TO GO ACROSS
THE CNTRY.
AND BY THE WAY,HERE IS HE
TONIGHT?
HE IS GOING BACK FOR HIS 33RD
TRIP TO DELAWARE.
HE HAS SPENT 25% OF HIS
PRESIDENCY AT OPERATION
WILMINON AT HOME.
THAT WILL BE FINE EXCEPT WHY
DIDN'T HE STOP OFF IN PHILLY AND
SA YOU KNOW WHAT, HERE IN
PENNSYLVANIA DOESN'TOOK LIKE
IT BUT YOU ARE LIVING IN A
BORDER STATE.
FENTANYL IS THE NUMBER ONE
KILLER OF 18-44-YEAR-OLDS, I'M
IS ON THE RISE, PEOPLE ARE
FLOODING INTO EVERY STATE,
ROUGHLY I WAS AN ATLANTA LAST
NIGHT WITH NEWT GINGRICH AND HE
WAS SANG IT IS BASICALLY IN
ATLAA EVERY MONTH CALMING OVER
THE BORDER, 7,000 PEOPLE A
DAYR SO.
ANYWAY YOU LOOK AT IT, THIS IS A
COUNTRY IN CRISIS, CHAOS,
CRISIS, AND A PRESIDENT -- VERY
QUICKL LOOK AT THE POLLS,
CLIMATE CHANGE AND COVID ARE NOW
WAY BELOW INFLATION,
IMMIGRATION, EDUCAON, CRIME,
AND OF COURSE NATIONAL SECURITY
AS A TOP ISSUE.
AND SO, JOHN KERRY JUST WANTS TO
BE POPULAR AT DABO'S.
HE WANTS TO MAKE SURE HE IS
CTURING THE REST OF US OVER
HIS FURROWED BROW AND HE IS
POPULAR AMONG THE FTIONAL
CROWD INTERNATIONAL.
JOE BIDEN CONTINUES TO CONFOUND
ME IN THIS WAY, HES NOT
MEETINGHE ISSUES AMERICANS ARE
CLEARLY TELLING EVERY
POLLSTER --
>> Pete: THAT'S EXACTLY
RIGHT --
MOST IMPORTANT TO THEM.
HE IS NOT EVEN PREACHING TO THE
CHOIR, HE IS STOPPING IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE ROAD WITH NO
ONE, BACK  THE CAMERA, THE
PERFECT METAPHOR FOR JOE BIDEN
TURNING HIS BACK ON THE COUNTRY
>> Pete: IT REALLY IS.
CLAY, THERE ARE NO OTHER
NETWOR WITH REPORTERS ACTUALLY
ASKING QUESTIONS AT THE BORDER.
AND BILL MELUGIN AND OTHERS DO,
HONDUR MIGRANTS SAY OPENLY,
I'M JT WAITING FOR M 23RD
BECAUSE ON MAY 23RD, I KNOW I
GOT A FREE TICKET.
>> PETE, THINK ABOUT WHAT W GOT
GOING ON HERE.
THE WHITE HOU IS STILL TRYING
TO DEFEND THE IDEA THATE ALL
HAVE TO WEAR MASKS ON AIRPLANES
AND WLE WE WALK AROUND IN
AIRPTS BECAUSE OF COVID.WHILE SS
THAT THE BORDER, THEY DON'T NEED
TO HAVE COVID EMERGENCIES
ANYMORE SO TITLE 42 CAN BE
REMOVED
YOU CAN'T MAKE SENSE OF THAT.
BIDEN HIMSELF ACTUALLY GOT ASKED
ABOUT IT, I KNOWOU SAW IT AND
EVERYBODSAW IT EARLIER THIS
WEEK AND TOTALLY BUNGLEDHAT
RESPONSE.
HE CONFUSED THE TWO.
IF YOU WATCH THE TAPE YOU JUST
PLAYED FROM SEATTLE, THIS IS
UNFORTUNATE.
LOOK, THERE WAS A LOT OF TALK
AND I KNOW KELLY ANDEARD IT
ABOUT T 25TH AMENDMENT
SURROUNDING DONALD TRUMP.
JOE BIDEN HAS DEMTIA.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW YOU CAN
WATCHIM EVERY SINGLE WEEK, HE
IS GETTING WORSE, HE IS NOT
MAKING ANY SENSE, HIS SPEECS,
EVEN WHEN HE IS READINGIRECTLY
OFF OF A TELEPROMPTER, OFTEN
DON'T MAKE A SENSE.
THE BIZARRE WHIERING, THE
TURNING THE BACK, WHO IS
TALKING TO?
THE SHAKING HANDS WITH PEOPLE
THAT DON'T EXIST, THIS IS A TIME
THAT IS NOT IN CONTROL -- I
DON'T TAKE ANY JOY IN IT BECAUSE
ALL OF OUR ENEMIES ARE TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF THE FACT WE HAVE AN
EMPTY SUITIGHT NOW IN THE
WHITE HOUSE AND IT IS ONLY GOING
TO GET WORSE OVER THE NEXT
COUPLE OF YEARS, A PETE, HE IS
TELLING EVERYBODY, AT LEAST
OBAMA REPORTEDLY, THAT HE IS
GOING TO RUN R REELECTION AT
THE AGE OF 82?
THIS IS MADNESS.
HE IS IN WORSE CONTROL OF HIS
FACULTY THAN ANY PRESIDENT WEHAN
STORY.
THIS IS AN EMBARRASSMENT.
I DON'T HOW WE GET OUT OF THIS
MESS BUT I KNOW IT IS NOT
GETTING ANY BETTER
>> Pete: THERE ARE SOMEMOMENTS T
IF IT WERE TRUMP" GAM, IF TRUMP
HAD DONE ONE-TTH OF THE THINGS
JOE BIN IS DOING NOW OTHER
CABLE PUNDITS WOULD BE YELLING
25TH AMENDMENT THERE IS NO
DOUBT ABOUT IT.
THAT IS N CONJECTURE, THAT IS
WHAT WE KNOW WHAT WOULD BE
HAPPENING.
YOU MENTIONED THE SCARY PART,
CLAY, I WANT TO GTO YOU
CHARLIE, NATNAL
IMPLICATIONS.
THE SOVEREIGNTY OF OUR BORDER
AND NOW YOU HAVE THE COMMANDER
IN CHIEF OBSESSING OVER ELECTRIC
HICLES IN OUR MILITARY AND
MAKI SURE WE DON'T AIM IT
BECAUSE OF CLIMATEHANGE AS
OPPOSED TO, I DON'T KW,
FIGURING O A WAY TO STARE DOWN
THE COMMUNIST CHINE SHOULD
THAT HAPPEN.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT IT THREE
NATIONAL SECURITY LENS, WE LOOK
FUNDAMENTALLY UNSERIOUS.
>> AND WE AREUNDAMENTALLY
UNSERIOUS.
AT LEAST JOE BIDEN CERTAINLY IS.
ONE OF THE ARGUMENTSHE
ADMINISTRATION MAKES ABOUT THE
TITLE 42 IS THERE BOUND BY LAW,
THEY HAVE TO RESPECT OF E
PARTICULARS OF THE LAW THAT
BROUGHT ABT TITLE 42 IN THE
FIRST PLACE.
WELL, MY GOODNESS, AREOU
KIDDING ME, WHEN YOU START
CARING ABOUT THE LAW?
THEY IGNORE THE LAW EVERY SINE
DAY ON THE BORDER.
THEY REFUSE TO ENFORCE T LAWS
THAT AREN THE BOOKS, THAT HAVE
BEEN ON THE BOOKS FORECADES.
THEY REFUSEDO ENFORCE ANY OF
THOSE LAWS.
SO THIS EA THAT SUDDENLY THEY
CARE ABOUT THE PARTICULARS OF
THE LAW, AS CLAY POINTS O, AT
TIME WHEN THEDMINISTRATION
ON THE OTHER STAND IS STILL
TRYING TO ENFORCE CID
REGULATIONS, BUT OF COURSE,
EVERYTHING IS POLITICALITH
THESE PEOPLE, EVERYTHINGS
LAWLESS WITH THESE PEOPLE, AND
THIS DISPLED TODAY -- AND IF
THERE IS ANYBODY IN WASHINGTON
WHO IS AS BIG A BUFFOON, PERHAPS
A BIGGER BUFFOON THAN JOE BIDEN,
IT IS JOHN KERRY.
THESE ARE THE TWO GREATEST
FOREIGNOLICY EXPERTS
WASHINGTON HAS BEEN ABLE TO
PRODUCE, FOR GOING BACKT LEAST
20 YEARS, A THEY HAVE CREATED
EVERY CRISIS WE ARE FACING RIGHT
NOW AND SO MANY OFHESE CRISES
ARE CAUSED OR ME WORSE BY TS
LUNACY ABOUT WINDMILLS AND
DESTROYING OUR ENERGY
INPENDENCE.
THAT I WHY VLADIMIR PUTIN
INVADED UKRAINE,T'S BECAUSE
JOE BIDEN IS IN THE WHITE HOUSE
AND CAUSE HE RAN OFF AFTER,
YOU KNOW, UNICOS AND FAIRY
DUST, TRYIN TO DESTROY
AMERICA'S ENERGY INDEPENDENCE.>Y
RIGHT.
KELLYANNE, TK ABOUT THIS,
THERE ARE YOUNG TEXAS
NATIONAL GUARD SDIERS TRYING
TO DO A JOB, ONE OF WHICH JUMPED
IN THE RIVER TO SAVE A MIGRANT,
ANDS MISSING AT THIS MOMT,
AND WE PRAY FOR HIM AND HIS
FAMILY BUT LIKELY WON'T END
WELL.
THERE ARE HUMAN CONSEQUENCES TO
THIS.
>> THERE ARE INDEED AND IN FACT
JUST YESTERDAY IAS SPEAKING TO
FORMER MEMBERS OF THE BORDER
COROL AND FORMER MEMBERS OFDHS E
THING, THA ON LIKE NEVER
BEFORE, AS SARA SAID, WE HAVE
BORDER PATROLGENTS DOING
PAPERWORK, THEY ARE JUST
CONSTANTLY PROCESSING PEOE,
HANDING OUT DIAPERS, BABY
FORMUL TRYING TO SAVE LIVES,
BECAUSE WE HAV A PREDENT OF
UNITED STATES AND MMANDER IN
CHIEF WHO REFUSES TO DO WITH
THIS NATION HAS DONE FOR DECADEE
BILLIONS, WHIC IS PROTECT OUR
OWN BORDERS.
WE HAVE TO PROTECT THE
SOVEREIGNTY AND DEND THE
BORDERS OF SO MANY OTHER NATIONF
YEARS AND WE ARE NOT DOING
AT RIGHT HERE.
NOW PEOPLE ARE WATCHING THIS AND
THEY KNOW IT, DO YOU KNOW THAT
IN MOST POLLI, THE NUMBER OF
AMERICS, INCLUDING SUBURBAN
WOMEN, INCLUDING -- WHO CARE
ABOU IMMIGRATION AND BORDER
CURITY IS HIGHER THAN WHEN
DONALD TRUMP WAS THERE AND HE
MADE THIS A CENTERPIE OF HIS
CAAIGN AND HIS WHITE HOUSE.
WHY IS THAT?
BECAUSTHEY NOTICE THERE IS
NOBODY MINDI THE STORE NOW,
NOBODY IN EIR RIGHT MIND
MINDING THE STORE AND I JUST
WANT TO MAKE A QUICK CORRECTION.
I UNDERSTAND WE ALL SEE
JOE BIDEN FAILG IN FRONT OF
US, BUT I WANT HIM TOWN ALL OF
HIS POLICIES, I DON'TANT TO
MAKE EXCUSES FOR HIM BECAUSE
THEN PEOPLE THINK BARACK AMA
IS RUNNING THE WHITE HOUSE OR
KAMALA HARRIS ISN'T TT BAD.
THIS GUY AND THE DEMOCRATS
SHOULD BE MADE TO EAT ALL OF THE
FAILINGND FLAILING SO THEY
WALK INTO THE MIDTERM ELECTIONS
IN NOVEMBER I DON'T KNOW WHAT
HIT THEM.
>> Pete: CLAY AND CHARLIE WE
ARE ALMOST OUT OF TIME, 30
SECONDSACH, SAME QUESTION, DO
YOU THINK THIS WHITE HSE,
BASED ON WHAT KELLYANNE SAID,
UNDERSTAND HOW DISCONNECTE THE
THINGS THEY AREURSUING ARE
FROM WHAT PEOPLE ARE FEELING?
CLAY?
>> I FEEL LIKE THEY ARE TRYING
TO INTENTIONALLY TANK, PETE.
THIS IS A SITUATION RIGHT NOW --
I CAN'T EXPLAIN IT IN ANY WAY.
IT IS LIKE EN YOU ARE TRYING
TO G THE NUMBER-ONE PICK IN
THE NBA OR THE NFL AND YOUR TEAM
KEEPS INTENTIONALLY LOSING.
THEY ARE INCOMPETENTN A LEVEL
I HAVE NEVER SEEN BEFORE.
IF TT'S WHAT IT FEELS LIKE
RIGHT NOW.
>> Pete: CHARLIE, INCOMPETENCE
OR IDEOLOGY THAT BLINDS THEM?
OR BOTH?
>> I THINK THEY AR COMPLETELY
SEIZED BY THIS IDEOLOGICAL
CRAZINESS AND I CAN'T SEE
ANYTHING ELSE, AND MY ONE
QUESTI IS THIS, THIS WEEK WE
SAW JEN PSAKI BURST INTO TEARS
TALKING ABOUT THAT LAW IN
FLORIDA T STOP PEOPLE FROM
TEACHING KINDEARTNERS ABOUT
TRANSSEXUALISM.
WILL SHERY FOR US OVERHAT
TEXAS NATIONAL GUARD?
THAT'S WHAT I WANT TO KNOW.
>> Pe: GREAT QUESTION.
IT'S A GRE